[Applause]
it's very bizarre I know I told my
husband I was coming on the show and
he's like oh my god that's so amazing I
was like I know I've heard so much about
you but I don't never met you so that's
hilarious oh my god I love those movies
the guardians of galaxy okay I'm fine
I'm fine
so your husband though he just Chris
Pratt he had a birthday right everybody
would jump get him I got him piggies
you got him actual pigs yeah what like
miniature ones no actually what happened
to me when I was in high school was I
rescued this supposed miniature Pig oh
when I lived at my parents house and it
turned into a giant pot-bellied pig and
rooted up my mom's entire lawn I'm just
laughing because if nobody's actually
had a huge but very enormous they're so
big very very large yeah that's bacon my
Pig
my little brother Christopher actually
named her bacon so it's his fault but
yeah he has we have an amazing place in
Washington State so there's a lot of
land there so the pigs are not living
with us yeah they're living in looking
very beautiful farm yeah loving life
very large now so I'm very excited that
they did not come to our house because I
was told they would say small and they
did not yeah I was told my dog was gonna
be miniature and lies and heifers like
45 pounds I'm like what he is not 15 to
18 pounds that's awesome this y'all have
a farm in Washington Washington's
beautiful yeah yes nice place to escape
that's yeah yeah I grew up around
animals so it's really fun and I did as
well I love it yeah it makes me so happy
animals are so cool they're just loyal
and nice and they're never mean so have
y'all ever had any unusual pets my I
just had this babysitter and she had a
rooster oh and I mean yeah that's the
thing yeah it was very mean yeah she
would go outside and she loved the
rooster because how can you not love
animals and she would go outside and try
to bond with it and it would try to bite
her yeah and
at a certain point it was chasing her
all around the yard and she climbed up a
tree and it bit her butt and it was oh
my god that happened to me one time and
a little petting zoo my sister I was
holding your problem this goat kept
nipping in my behind I was like because
I was holding your kid like firm the
goat and like my sister's just laughing
and I'm like it's eating my boss anyway
no I love rain and pets though I love I
love all kinds of pets especially farms
it's nice to get out in like the
wilderness like just that just out of a
having them in like a home in the city
though - yeah yeah yeah I also grew up
like that my dad has a miniature pony
and a donkey currently that he brings in
the house in your house in his house yes
oh you good correction you can do
whatever you want yo okay well let's
talk about your book so the gift of
forgiveness what inspired you to do this
really just life I think I you know felt
as many of us do like I was struggling
with forgiveness in my own life and I
went to try and find help and and
resources and I couldn't find anything
that really spoke to me and I felt that
speaking to other people about their
journeys and their struggles is really
what inspired me to be able to go to my
life and practice forgiveness so there I
decided it's you know ya create that and
this book has a series of incredible
stories that are just really
mind-blowing and these people have all
been able to talk about practicing
forgiveness and struggling with
forgiveness and some still struggling
with it so it's a really awesome story I
think it's amazing because even though
sometimes in my life I feel like I have
forgiven a situation then you're like oh
this isn't just like a one-time thing
I've got practicing at this yeah
like because I did oh yeah it was
actually something interesting that was
in the book and also interesting because
people are always like okay so what's
the quick fix on how do I practice
forgiveness and I keep reminding people
that what forgiveness means to you is
something totally than what it means to
me which makes it so much more
complicated but also really interesting
because for a lot of us it's a
one-and-done thing which in the in my
book there are some people who practice
forgiveness and they're done and they're
good and there are a lot of us like
myself who it's an ongoing process and
so what I like to say to people is that
I have struggled with forgiveness and
I've been able to practice it but I'm a
fellow struggler with forgiveness and
it's an ongoing process but when I
struggle I'm able to now draw
inspiration from the stories in my book
to kind of help get me through and
that's been incredibly helpful for me
yes because some of the people you
interviewed that's a that's a hefty
amount of forgiving I know these names
are like Elizabeth Smart sue Klebold
Pablo Escobar's son Sebastian Joaquin we
have so many incredible amazing people
in the book and just a really wide range
of stories which was really important to
me people from all different backgrounds
all walks of life all different faiths
some with no faith so it was important
to me to get a good mixture of people
who've experienced different yeah and so
somebody can read it and relate to
something and also I encourage people to
kind of pick it up and put it down
because it is a lot heavy yeah it's a
heavy read but it's also really
inspiring because people gave me the
gift of just really being so open and
honest and raw and vulnerable with me
which was incredible yeah and now if
anybody who gets to read it so have
y'all do you feel like you've ever had
to dig deep to like forgive someone I
have forgiven I probably need to read
the book you're a you're 11 but hey a
lot a lot of people count kids out but a
lot of things happen when you're a kid
that can be devastating like I mean my
girls five years old and she has had her
heart broken already just by friendships
you know yeah by all the sudden like
some girls just like mean to write I
know and she's like wait I thought we
were friends you know that mean are you
devastating it is you know like uh
especially this generation like I feel
like too many kids are worried about how
other people see them instead of how
they see their it's a daily conversation
and they have to fit in and match
everybody and it's just like that's how
it is like either you're in in the group
or you're out and it's like it shouldn't
be that way you should just accept
everybody for you know how they are and
that's how you have real friends if
you're the real
yeah subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going